hello there reject nation I'm Greg Emma
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch top
10 best video games for causing chaos
from watchmojo.com there's a tough war
tear video requests from patron Andrew
Hayes I'm excited to check it out
he loves gaming I like games John knows
what games are I've played a game let's
do this if you're one of those who watch
the world burn tied players these games
were made just for you welcome to
watchmojo.com fish right here causing
chaos for this list we're looking at
video games that give players free rein
to wreak havoc regardless if that's the
main purpose of the game or not whether
you're blowing things up smashing
through obstacles or just being a plain
old jerk one more game visit justice and
there gonna be any other games Red Dead
Redemption white
please number-10 Katamari Damacy oh yeah
the QT graphics may not look that
chaotic but appearances can be deceiving
this ps2 cult classic follows the Prince
son of the king of all cosmos are
pairing a crazy night of drinking the
king accidentally destroys all stars
you're given a katamari a superadhesive
ball to roll around and collect enough
objects in quaint environments to
rebuild the stars that sounds like a
blast the kids actually is surprisingly
small the flavor at some point was but
in later levels you can suck up living
things like birds
rats elephants and eventually humans
though they'll all try to scamper away
can you imagine going about your day
when all of a sudden you're flailing
around on a ball and then turn into a
star
number nine goat simulator haha ah but
are these games know you before everyone
was all gung ho about geese this simple
game let players cause mayhem as one of
nature's other chaotic animals it's not
nearly as polished and experienced what
any game on this list but it's
intentionally broken mechanics are also
part of its charm
there's no real goal here only to gain
points by getting into trouble every
wish you could roam a sandbox
environment bashing innocent citizens
with your skull you can do it you can
knock over any environment 100%
invincible and you can perform crazy
stunts with ragdoll physics it's simple
silly it's mayhem and it's fun oh man
someone control one game I have an idea
number eight ultimate what what as the
name would suggest this team title lets
you create any battle you can come up
with the only limit is your imagination
well and how powerful your PC is if you
want to see 10,000 Knights take on
hordes of the undead it's got you
covered
how about reenacting the 300 Spartans
against the 20,000 Persian rule or what
if the Romans faced a horde of killer
chickens whatever use each character is
independently towards the goal mix team
but you can also play as one of the so
happy giving commands and turning the
tides or you can switch sides just to
make the mayhem lasts a little bit long
oh it's pure and utter yeah guns and for
the dentist that's really the highest
compliment we can give it
7210 kills number seven rampage series
oh there's something familiar there's
two my Johnson back parachuting
this classic series was literally
designed to let players tear cities
apart so of course it makes the list of
giant animals and stomp their way
through various landscapes eating as
many people as they can along the way
[Music]
most of the time your character options
are giant gorilla lizard or wolf chaos
is encouraged as the more destruction
you caused and the more citizens you
consume the higher your points rise the
army is set to stop you age just as
satisfying to rip helicopters out of the
air as it is the goblets I can see how
you can make an emotional moving film
it's all here I feel like the movie
really captured the tone and spirit of
this game your six
really
Big Willie
if rampage leads you desiring a little
more gameplay variety and how you caused
terror in the hearts of humans you may
want to test out this franchise each
game in the series revolves around
crypto an alien tasked with protecting
or improving his race but doing so
brings him into direct conflict with
people who are woefully unprepared for
an encounter with the Third Kind crypto
uses psychic abilities and laser guns
though he also gains access to a flying
saucer and in one game a giant mech
destructible environments and ragdoll
physics of the humans make causing
pandemonium immensely fun and it makes
you want to cause more than is entirely
necessary there's like no destruction
you know it is a real game like a real
game ultimate destruction the game would
have to let you wreak as much havoc as
possible luckily for us this action
title does not disappoint
the game follows dr. Bruce Banner as he
tries to create a machine no control his
condition while simultaneously being
hunted by the NSA you're given certain
instruction causing missions but also
the freedom to roam sandbox environments
you'll find it hard to focus on the task
at hand when you can rip through
buildings run across walls leap
astounding Heights and smack vehicles
and citizens out of your way like it's
nothing so they don't hurt people but
you're not to hold into the same moral
restraints oh damn
number four untitled goose game
wonderful it's called untitled he's
causing chaos doesn't always come with
destruction
sometimes it just means being a dick and
it's here where untitled goose game
source there's not much in terms of
story you control the film in a small
village who simply likes messing with
the humans areas
Oh mind you can scare the hell out of
them just by honking you can even add
insult to injury by talking them with a
flap of your wings there's a very good
reason this game became an instant hit
upon release he started Toria Slee the
jerks of the animal kingdom and it feels
fantastic to take a walk in their shoes
or rather their webbed feet hi number
three oh yeah
some would argue this open world action
series is merely a wackier version of
GTA but we would argue that that's not a
bad thing a lot from its predecessor
letting players wage war against
humanity around them well but it's in
the fourth entry where things truly went
off the rails in this fashion
huh in a ridiculous turn of events your
character is given superpowers oh good
you can run around committing your
standard massive yeah but with the added
bonus of being superhuman for anyone
around you out of the way and if you get
cornered just use your SuperSpeed to
escape I would just skip to this one in
my place Saints Row without superpowers
Oh haha number two just cause series now
we're gaining some really well Dover
Grantham dog I mean number one probably
it's it's the official games take place
in sprawling open environments and the
Just Cause series features some of the
biggest players control Rico Rodriguez a
secret agent who visits a different
war-torn island in each game to defend
against dictators and militia groups you
become a one man army commandeering any
vehicle or weapon you want in order to
stop your enemies Jason Momoa man
[Music]
the variety and traversal helps to act
in mayhem as you can also go skydiving
parasailing or use a wingsuit in the
third and fourth entries plus the game's
award you for causing destruction with
chaos points these are used to on the
missions vehicles and weapons because I
didn't keep the chaos train so much
chaos before we get to our most
destructive pick here are a few
honorable mentions big surprise
well I have left
[Music]
Nintendo's harder uh-huh interesting
choices job yeah glad I was wondering if
this might make him there's a blast what
this game oh yeah
TUC cheese's before we continue be sure
to subscribe to our channel and ring the
bell to get notified that's that's have
videos you have to be notified for
occasional videos or all of them if
you're on the phone company go into your
settings it's switch what if that
occasional video is the one I really
want to get notified number one ran
Theft Auto series
tis the whole thing yeah well hard to
beat the series that popularized causing
mayhem in sandbox environments and it's
undoubtedly one of the shining aspects
that has made it one of gaming's most
popular franchises each entry gives you
an absolute arson to work with and many
players have lost hours to rampaging
through each city
it's almost a game in and of itself
seeing how long you can make it before
the cops get you and with the addition
of online the series has only become
even more chaotic one must only look at
out of time eta has been cited as
dangerous by Paulo hands you know that
it is the absolute I'm constantly
getting a bunch of time guns don't kill
people video games do in the mood for
more awesome gaming content be sure to
check out this video here on mojo plays
and subscribe so why isn't the game
hatred on here ah that is probably the
number one most chaos cause honest game
it even caused chaos and culture itself
I mean that hot second that game is pure
evil it's pretty sure you haven't even
leveling all about just going out and
killing people massacring the only thing
here yes sir that game you're really in
the shoes of a mass shooter it is awful
super entertaining to play I mean
excellent taste this is the trailer load
and shock the world yeah I would say
hatred should be on here at least in an
honorable mention capacity maybe because
I feel like hatred everybody heard about
it saw the trailer but I don't think
many people actually played hatred I
feel like it was a sort of outraged
curiosity yeah fade it away but GTA is
just like prolific in how much it's not
only fed into this list but also upset
people in culture well I mean I think
GTA is the best one because it's like
some people I know actually prefer
Saints Row because of how much more wild
it is a more sane e and cartoony it is
but I think GTA is the best one because
the white word isn't grounded it's a
little more grounded than other it's the
mace of one where I feel like you live
the most vicariously through I mean as
its progressed it's gotten crazier but
to be a real criminal at least in like
criminal movie world yeah really
experience that because that's what I
remember really honing in on were
special about time gta3 came around and
then by city with Ray Liotta voicing the
main character and then a play on
Scarface and then as a
going they keep riff on other things and
it's got a lot more outlandish sense but
I do get why GTA would be the number one
consider I feel like Red Dead Redemption
could be an honorable mention too like
most games from a new rock stars can
Rockstar yes their advisors all these
Easter Egg a video game Easter eggs
would be loved
horrifyingly long video but from
Rockstar I think most of their games
should be on here because like with Red
Dead Redemption it's like you're in the
Wild West maybe you can't cause as much
chaos because you don't have access to
vehicles or crazy technology like steam
guns but you can cause a lot of mayhem
and then you have the similar setup that
if you break the law like cops come
after you and you could cause a whole
bunch of destruction as well you blow
stuff up still so I think Red Dead
Redemption could be an honorable mention
you know trying to add to this list but
there are games here that I most of
these I haven't even heard about
oh man I mean missing out like means
some great games The Incredible Hulk one
I think would be a total blast that's a
real game right yeah I remember when
this came out and I didn't know the
details of that but to live through the
Hulk will be a blast I thought that'd be
a cool VR game yeah and to not have
loves not necessarily have to be
concerned with the Hulk's morality you
can just go and do what you want like
that was the biggest thing I was
wondering during that clip I was like
it's the Hulk I hero in this game or it
can you be kind of anything you want so
you can smack through civilians if you
want yeah it could be a blast
dude Elseworlds Hulk I mean a VR hope
game causing rampage on and looking at
the rampage footage I was like movie did
not capture the spirit you know it took
the ideas of buildings being destroyed
by big creatures Yeah right to make
something with more gravitas behind yeah
weird crossroads point hey man Wayne
Johnson really cared about that gorilla
okay part yeah that's why people play
rampages to feel something is should've
just been a silly ass movie with humans
having to survive amongst giant Apes
yeah that's all should have been there
you go the funny thing is I didn't
realize just how much chaos that goat
simulator allowed you to wreak because
I've heard of goat simulator before and
I've seen like little demos and I must
have just seen like very mellow
because I thought the gag of goat
simulator was that you just do goat
stuff yeah but no apparently you could
just go Gore P I love this trend of like
different animal games where you get to
go around and Gore and Massacre people
the goose one - who's ones my favorite
because it's so subtle yeah they're not
killing people is just annoying because
I would go to the rampaging through like
I love how high on the list it was that
I'm like yeah I would have to because
the other ones kind of bleed together
because they're all just essentially the
same thing more more more more more more
more more more sponges slows down and
goes how do we subtly piss people off
yeah I'm not gonna do mass destruction
we're just going to wreck everybody's
day sorry goose really known to be like
annoying animals oh I know they can be
very assertive and they can be kind of
pushy especially if you go to like a
park with a lake and you got a picnic or
something goose let's come right up to
you'd be like what's up give me some
food we should get goose uh-huh I think
so keep it outside so in case anybody
comes in just chase them right off oh
yeah the cats we get along definitely
the cats will love the goose the goose
would keep the cats in line they would
be freaked out by his big old wings you
know I didn't know any of these things
now what adults have to do with goose oh
you hit people's heads and then you know
everybody who's a duck is safe and then
whoever's the goose has to chase
everybody now why do maverick and goose
get along oh you know because goose had
that mustache right yeah I like the
battle one oh yeah the one where you can
like pick any circumstances for a war
that you want do you play that game or
do you watch it play yeah like I was
confusing how you play in it yeah I was
like you just picked your armies and
then just like send them towards each
other's watch or do you have to
strategize in any way are you one of
these soldiers I can't really get into
most chaos games
I need like objectives they got swell
grant that thought Oh lenses I'm like
Just Cause lends itself to that to their
mission games at the end of the day like
you can around it cause mayhem but at
the end of the day you do have
objectives to really complete missions I
feel like GTA balances everything out
because there is objective there's a
story there is a structure but you don't
really have to engage with it like
pertinently so you have almost like a
Sims s quality running in the background
where if you want to you can just do
side missions and live life but yeah the
other one that we both got excited about
that has the similar quality as Simpsons
there because you know you've got the
Crazy Taxi element but you can just go
around and destroy stuff as The Simpsons
which is super fun ya know these are
fine
alright guys what games do you think
should have been on here leave a comment
below subscribe to the real rejects
please click that notification bell get
notified never got a youtube video up
Andrew thanks for requesting this dude
one day you and I are gonna hang out in
New Jersey and we're gonna cause chaos
on streets we're gonna burn people's
homes down I wrote set geese on fire mhm
alright a goat right a goat all through
the rivers and the poverty driven areas
of New Jersey it's gonna be a blast dude
and then you will take the fall for
everything I got too much writing and
I'm like I'm going a career it's going
places right now Andrew you gotta take
the fall for me but I'll cause most of
the destruction but you gotta take the
fall and while you both are busy with
all that I'm gonna be rolling trash
around town cleaning up the streets of
New Jersey sending that big old ball
into the sky and creating new stars new
rock stars I'm Eric Foss and these have
been the Easter eggs